Alright, we've got VIP tickets sold 2, general admission, 4. Very cool.
>> Got it.
>> Okay But this is obviously wrong. Tickets sold should be 6, not 0.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> Should I do another roll-up summary?
>> Well, we could do another roll-up summary, but you
can only have ten roll-up summaries per object, and we might
want to calculate some other things, so. Instead of using a
roll up summary, we can do what's called a formula field.
>> Okay.
>> Very similar, but it's a little bit more dynamic and you have
more functionality you can add to it.
>> Okay.
>> But really, all we're obviously trying to
do here, is adding those two numbers together.
>> 2 plus 4. So, how should I add this formula field?
>> Well why don't you try and figure it out?
>> Okay.